foreign
hit just a few moments ago student loan
forgiveness is not happening it is
official now the Supreme Court
officially struck down Biden student
loan debt relief plan that would have
forgiven up to 20 grand for federal
student loan borrowers and Rachel and I
put an Instagram story out just kind of
sharing the news giving people some next
steps in a meeting uh and you know the
texts were coming in that the Supreme
Court had ruled this and it was like oh
my gosh because we've been talking about
this for 18 months it feels like seven
years from the moment it was announced a
long time and if you've been listening
to the show you know that we've our
number one thing for you guys is that we
want you debt free we want you out of
debt so we're like listen if this passes
and you take advantage of it go that's
great if you have a moral conviction
against it then don't but it's not
passed yet don't wait on someone else
you know to make decisions AKA
Washington to fix your life so continue
to pay it on because there was no
interest right now there was a pause on
interest you could be paying down the
principal all this right so this is in
our head so George and I
I'm like George oh my gosh they shut it
down like it's not happening let's jump
on the social because that's where
people are to you know just give the
announcement talk about it
apparently we are too happy about it
it's what people were saying they said
we were too political and so then we had
to do another video to be like yo it's
not that we're like wanting people to to
suffer we just always knew this was the
case so all that to say there is uh a
lot of emotion around this which we
understand because also you guys we hate
student loans we hate this whole
industry it is predatory people these 18
year olds sign sign their lives away and
they had no clue what they're doing the
people the adults in their lives whether
ignorant or believes something else
Usher them into this like the whole
thing is frustrating so we are against
this whole industry so we're not for it
so we want you out of it
um but we also know that you're the one
that's gonna have to change your life
and and sitting and waiting around on
any program or any one person to do that
you're not going to get the change that
you want
great great way to put that Rachel the
big thing for us is we're not glad
because people aren't getting help we're
glad that the will they won't they game
is over and that you're not being lied
to anymore and that you don't have this
false hope and that you're in control
now you can actually do something about
this instead of waiting on a politician
and Ken you were on Fox news earlier
today talking about this very issue yeah
and I think you just hit on the real
problem with this understandably
whether you agree with us on debt and
loans and you're just kind of checking
the show out or you saw their post and
you were offended uh let me just say
that I'm angry for you because if you
believed and a lot of you did millions
of you believed that this was possible
that's not fair to you this is an
emotionally charged issue because on the
other side of it as I mentioned on Fox
News today there were millions of
Americans I'm one of them who did take
out student loans and did pay them off
my wife too who was a masters in
broadcasting and so this was an
emotionally charged issue from the
get-go from all sides from all sides and
I think it's important to point that out
and and I I appreciate you guys saying
this I'll be honest with you it bothers
me that you guys and the reason you feel
the need to address is because you're
both really nice sweet people I'll be
honest nicer and sweeter than me because
the reality is is that what we have said
for 18 months or however long it was is
that folks we didn't think this was
gonna ever take place because of the
constitutionality of it we didn't file
the lawsuit multiple states did you had
private student loan firms that were
going to file lawsuits so here's where
we stand we can help you get rid of this
debt but you signed up for this
you did yeah and so there's a
responsibility into Rachel's point
I know it's bone crushing today and I
guess my point is is I I want to throw
some empathy out to say we get it
because you are struggling and it hurts
today and come August there's going to
be a lot of people hurting when these
loan payments start back up so here's
the point we want to make to you
we believe in you we have a process
called the baby steps that have worked
for millions of Americans and regardless
of who's President and who's in Congress
and who's in charge we don't want you to
fall for this stuff anymore we want you
to get serious about getting free from
debt and that's what I want to encourage
those people that are hurting today yes
and I hate that begs to the point too
you guys that there's like paying for a
system even like debt consolidation like
all these like things in the financial
industry that feel like shortcuts
it's always going to backfire like
there's a point that like things are
gonna by far and y'all were saying
earlier um it may have been you George
in our meeting as we're talking about
this that that actually people during
this waiting period of 18 months student
loan they were getting money back now
that they're going to have to pay again
like they're gonna have to pay back it's
like student loan companies were saying
hey we'll refund you now we'll refund
you here's your 10 grand back we're
going to reinstate your loan balance and
good luck with the government for giving
this that's a punch in the guts now
those people like it's just like it's
all of that stuff you guys so it's so
entangled and as we sit on this side of
the desk trying to help give hope and
empowerment to people when we see this
this narrative play and again regardless
of party like Republicans do this
Democrat like it's we see this stuff and
it's so and it's so hard because we also
know as we sit on the said desk that we
have people that stand on the debt free
the debt free stage that do debt-free
screams they've worked hard they've
sacrificed and they've done it so we
know that you can do this and so the
fact that we're not going to be talking
about this anymore in that sense of like
this waiting game I'm gonna wait and see
it no now you can put action to your
life and that's what we're excited about
yeah I can't tell you how many calls
we've taken in the last year or two just
people going should I do this because
what if they forgive it and I'm going
you're putting your life on hold and
putting your faith in a politician when
in history has it ever been a good idea
yeah and George I remember when they
first even announced this 18 months ago
I think we were on the air because it
was a day or two after we had people
a friend but like that we both know
kind of get mad at us they're like why
would you tell people to keep paying on
their student loans like they were
because we're like because it's probably
not going to happen they're like are you
kidding yes like it was a disagreement
there and we're just like oh my gosh no
keep paying because there's no interest
right now you could be putting down the
principle like it just mathematically
makes sense so um
that we are here for you for those of
you that are wanting to move forward in
your education and you think the only
way is student loan debt I can promise
you it's not we're here for you on that
yeah some of you are going wait a second
what do I do I don't want to get stuck
in this deal and so that's the point we
want to make today is that no matter
what you're feeling on either side of
this
um you can live life debt free that's
all we're trying to tell you give us a
chance to walk you and talk you through
it that's what we want people here today
because I can't point out enough how
many people are devastated emotionally
today devastated over this decision but
now it's what are we going to do next
because we can only wallow for so long
and so your payments are restarting in
October interest starts in September
we've got to make a plan we've got to
get on a budget we've got to pay this
debt off and we are here to help you
because we believe you're the hero not
the government yes that's how it's been
for 30 years and that is not changing
and uh you know I'll run on that
campaign promise Ken I'll vote for you
thank you somebody give me a ballot I'll
write your name in thanks for hanging
out Rachel thanks guys for having me
thanks Rachel this is the Ramsey Show